the best advice that I don't think
short-term think five years from today
this decision how will it impact even
though we try make as much money as we
can the quick place
empires are built on a second repurchase
the second time they come back so that's
the interesting component of that as
well so our last speaker is a man from
the United Kingdom who is a very
successful property investor and he is
now seeking those deals all over Europe
all over the UK but now he's looking to
do deals in South Africa and it doesn't
matter where you are our property is
property the country does not make the
difference the difference is the
property investor okay now here's a
secret there's a property investor don't
be a property investor be a property
entrepreneur you're an entrepreneur
that's in property not a property
investor trying to be an entrepreneur
that is the best advice that I got many
years ago so please give a big welcome
to our last speaker
Samuel Leeds everyone
well good morning South Africa how we
are doing amazing you guys are
incredible I've always wanted to go to
South Africa I've been all over the
world in different parts of it there's
six countries in Africa and I landed in
South Africa 48 hours ago and so far
loving it thank you
so one of the things I've noticed my
name is Samuel Leeds and I'm a property
entrepreneur as well as investor how
many of you'd like to be a property
entrepreneur how many of you would like
to bank a lot of money in property raise
your hands say hi amazing well you're in
the right room well one of the things
I've noticed in every country I go in is
there seems to be seven lies in society
that are taught in pretty much every
country across the world in Africa
Europe Asia there's seven lies that will
you've probably been told growing up
which will strip you of your success so
I wondered if it was okay if I just
exposed those lives right now son okay
all right so this is one of my books
where I exposed them and seven lives you
will have been told this and this could
be worthwhile having a listen so when I
was at school we finally told my
teachers that I wanted to become a
property investor they would have said
that it was risky they would have told
me that if I want you to guarantee
success I needed to follow their system
I'm sure you're familiar with it one
study hard at school as it's important
you get good grades
oops did I just say that go on to
university if you want to be paid well
get a good job for life if you buy a
house pay off the mortgage as quickly as
possible save as much as you can to
store away safely in the bank the harder
you work the more money you make and
look forward to retirement because
that's the good life
have you been told these I knew it it's
my first time in South Africa I just
need having told these seven things it's
everywhere I noticed it's crazy where is
the truth is one most people do not
benefit from good grades some of you are
thinking I'm glad I didn't bring my kids
right now I'd have just ruined them for
life right there to most people who
finish University still struggle to get
a job a good job for life does not exist
paying off the mortgage quickly is not
smart your money is shrinking in the
bank some of the poorest people are the
hardest workers and if retirement is
your motivation you will be extremely
disappointed true so thank you now I
haven't got time to hone into all of
those but I wanted to hole into one of
those points which I think is I could
express hopefully well and this will
change your mindset around money so here
we go that's me Samuel eats feel free to
google me check me out or find me in the
break so I'd love to get to know you
guys all right
those were the seven lies were they good
well they're actually really bad but the
seven truths were good so okay Bank
people say that if you put your money in
the bank that's a safe investment you
might not get the best return on
investment but it's safe do they say
that yes so what kind of return on
investment do you get from putting money
in the bank what kind of return but
basically zero maybe like 0.1 or
something you might put fifty thousand
pounds or five hundred thousand ran and
you'll make a few quid a year I get it
so if you put fifty thousand pounds in
the bank you can have to wear a very
long time to see that go up at all
you're not going to make you much return
true so let's say you wait 10 years
after waiting 10 years you're 50,000
pounds will now be worth around about
still only how much
fifty-one thousand wrong around about
36,000 how so
get this money shrinks over time if you
have money in the bank right now it is
shrinking so the idea of putting money
safely in the bank
the idea is taught from the bankers but
it's not true now I was fortunate enough
to have mentors and I got into property
a very young age I got into property
around about 2008 and I was a teenager I
bought my first house at 18 I bought six
more at 19 by the age of 21 I had a
million pound property portfolio never
had to work again thank you thank you
and the main thing I can teach you about
property is this and this is pretty much
the case anywhere around the world I've
done a little bit of research that's 48
hours in the beautiful South Africa if
you put that same 50,000 pounds into a
house on average certainly in the UK and
I'm sure this is true for South Africa
in the UK properties every 10 years
doesn't it doesn't shrink properties
double in value do it have we seen some
it's similar in South Africa over the
last 1,500 years you look your
grandparents you're probably like you
bought a house four words
yes double every 10 years so you put
50,000 pounds into a house ten years
later it's worth what 100 wrong 100 if
you buy the house for cash which a smart
investor in a property entrepreneur
would not do they would find a way to
finance it
so the 50,000 would be a deposit does
this make sense in my case 25 percent
deposit which means the house is worth
200 tell me what doubles the deposit on
the house will the house the house which
means you've now got a house worth four
hundred thousand pounds almost half a
million we call that leverage so you can
have the same two people that go to the
same school that have the same job
they both say 50,000 pounds one puts it
into a bank one puts it into a house one
person ends up broke one person ends up
rich and this is why communism doesn't
work Jim Rohn says he teaches kids to
have two bicycles once a ride wants a
rent how hard does it get with a little
ingenuity got it so and also you get
capital depreciation as well as cash
flow which is fantastic so I wanted to
give you three quick lessons before I go
there's going to be some people in the
room who say this doesn't apply to me
I've got no money
if that's you what I would say is I
would urge you to just manage the money
that you have I've traveled all over
Africa and I see people praying for more
money
please Lord give me more money I just
need more money then I'll give more to
charity then Oh tithe to my church I
just need more money and like the little
boy with the ice cream every time he
takes Olympic Falls all over him and he
ends up his dad gives him a freeze pot
because he can't manage the ice cream in
the same way God says to your prayers
I'll give you more when you manage more
faithful with a little just making sense
to manage what you have next if now I
aren't from a church background and as I
started to become more successful in
property my church got more and more
upset with me they did they the preacher
would look me right in the eye he'd be
like the love of money cause his evil
nuts right at me and these two give me
little quiet words so I ended up going
to Bible College I spent three years
studying biblical economics I came to
the conclusion that money is not good or
bad it's just at all as long as you hold
it like this you've open hands and a
generous heart then god bless you thank
you thank you
the problem is when you start holding it
like this mine you can't serve God and
money but you can serve God through
money and when I realized this I began
to stop subconsciously sabotaging my own
success because of stupid spirituality I
realized that some of the best hospitals
schools orphanages that were set up
we set up by capitalists but generous
capitalists and when I released myself
from the guilt I started making a lot
more so if you're thinking money's not
that important as Zig Ziglar says it's
not the most important thing in the
world but it ranks up there with oxygen
and you can't help the poor by being
like them so if you've got the capacity
go do it next you might have a lot of
money step 3 you might have money in the
bank shrinking if that's the case
investing in property but more
importantly the best thing to invest it
in yourself is you so congratulations
for being here
my name's Samuel etes god bless you
thank you
[Applause]